dawn
I need to know we're not making this
worse tell me you know what you're doing
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 14 video like father
like daughter
52 time loops so we got to break this
down there was also a big teaser for why
crisis on Infinite Earths is happening
so much sooner than in that original
future newspaper so I'll explain all the
foreshadowing scenes there's a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the
episode on the video obviously careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
so top 10 WTF and Easter eggs here we go
number 10 they've finished the metahuman
cure but it's gonna take an hour cooking
in the pan dimensional microwave that is
the speedforce because they need all
those tachyons so that explains why
Barry is out of commission for the
entire episode this is actually one of
their better reasons for sidelining
Barry because there's like certain
budgetary reasons why they can only have
so much speedster stuff happening on
screen at once like it's crazy expensive
to have Barry and Nora running around at
the same time and if you have killer
frost stuff going on and they have to do
special effects for cicada whenever he
throws his dagger so if you ever
wondered why there's a character that's
really powerful or someone with really
cool special effects isn't around for an
episode that's usually why it's usually
because they're saving money because
next week's episode is gonna be Gorilla
Grodd vs King shark it is probably gonna
be one of the most expensive episodes
that they do all season long because
they have to mocap both of those actors
when they're performing them on screen
there were a lot of references to
earlier seasons as well like when Cisco
says 29 days usually it takes us way
longer to take down a big bad than that
that's just a reference to previous
seasons like when they were fighting
zoom or reverse flash in the first
season or savat are in the third season
how it usually takes them till the last
couple of episodes before they're able
to defeat a big bad number 9 was all of
Cisco's cringy dates they tried to use
it for comedy I was kind of glad that
they brush past this pretty quickly
because they're trying to make this
Camilla character a bigger thing and
it's possible that Cisco is gonna leave
the show at the end of the season and
Camilla is gonna have something to do
with that storyline the really big
easter egg you probably spotted was for
season 3 during this avatar storyline
during the first date when he goes in
trying to be the businessman he
basically tells her he's Cisco of Ramon
industries Ramon industries
was the name of STAR Labs during
flashpoint where he basically did
everything that he tells her during this
day like wait a minute you profit off of
other people's inventions
hey somebody has to number eight the
first time loop though this time he
captures iris in her office and throws
the dagger but it gets killer frost
killing her so remember the danielle
panabaker was directing the episode so
that's why you didn't see a whole lot of
killer frost after this first time loop
it was always mostly the same version of
Caitlin's scene in that main room when
she would come back to the beginning of
the timeline that was just easier for
danielle Panabaker to film those scenes
because most of the time she was behind
the camera telling the other actors what
to do number seven though she comes back
for the next time loop Sherlock starts
to notice what's going on this time it's
Ralph that winds up dying but there's a
bottle of Jing cold soda they haven't
had an Easter Egg for that in a while
they did it a lot during season 4 when
they first introduced the character
because it was the soda in the Silver
Age flash comics that gave him his power
so anytime you see him sitting in his
office drinking something it usually
winds up being the jingle soda just to
pay reference to that number six time
loop number three this time it's
Sherlock that gets captured in Cisco
starts to vibe thing x' during his days
noticing so he comes in and he's the one
that gets it in the back nor it goes
back in number five time loop number
four this time she really flips out gets
them all to stay in the lounge but it's
a seal that dies she actually dies
before she gets there she runs up and
the daggers already in Cecile's back but
here's where things start to get really
crazy number four time loop number 52 so
there was this big montage after Cecile
died when she ran back that's meant to
be a visual representation of all those
other times that she traveled back
because including that first time loop
she only runs back four times so I think
they just wanted to visually compress
that so if you were confused about what
all those images worth that's how they
got to that 52 or technically 53 number
[Music]
but I love the look on their faces when
she walks in you're changing the
timeline aren't you because every time
she's reset the timeline Cisco's vibes
have gotten bigger and bigger so you
just have to assume that off screen
before she walked in Cisco was like dude
everybody I've been having deja vu crazy
something is going on the really cool
thing about the pep talk she gets from
Cisco is that it also makes her wonder
about what's going on with reverse-flash
a little bit more making him seem a
little more suspicious because he's been
all like trust me Nora I'm the only one
that can help you with this timeline
problem
he suspiciously omitted the fact that he
killed Barry Allen's mother Nora's
grandmother she got really pissed when
she found out about that so if she
seemed really pissed off with
reverse-flash at the end of the episode
that was part of the reason why but
mostly because of that coffee cup
explainer but number three team Flash's
actual plan to use all their abilities
together once they're in that 53rd time
loop so it's actually a pretty cool
visual effect they use Cisco's vibes in
combination with killer frost frost
ability in Nora's ability to rewind time
to get everybody to safety and get
cicada into the right path of the dagger
so that it will hit him instead of one
of them and it's totally successful he
flies away remember he can only fly with
the dagger but the dagger is stuck in
his chest so that's why it looks like
he's flying of his own accord and he's
gonna be on ice during next week's
episode like they say that there's no
traces of dark matter that just means
that he got wounded so badly that he's
gone to ground because the next episode
is gonna be all about Grodd versus King
shark which it means it's gonna be crazy
expensive so they're gonna focus mostly
on those characters for the episode the
funny thing about their solution though
is that it's almost like you know
embracing everyone's abilities to their
fullest extent be yourself because
that's kind of what Cisco speech was
about but as Barry tells her later her
ability to rewind time is probably one
of the most dangerous abilities that
anyone on the team has so number two
Barry's Jay Garrick copy cup timeline
speech you can try and reset things as
much as you want but you'll never
completely fix it and you'll only crack
the coffee cup more now you can
try and reset the timeline try to fix it
but no matter how hard you try it's
never gonna be exactly how it was
where have you go back in time it breaks
not real I mean you could reset the
timeline you can try to fix it but no
matter how hard you try
there's no don't be exactly how it was
so remember how Barry tried to change
the timeline a couple times and how bad
it went with Savitt our Nora just did it
52 times so Barry is not joking when
he's talking about there being
consequences to this something is
fundamentally going to change because of
how Nora was trying to mess with the
timeline in this sort of paid that
forward in the reverse-flash scene as
well which is why I think that that's a
reference to why crisis on Infinite
Earths is happening this fall during
2019 instead of during 2024 because of
all the crazy coffeeCup timeline edits
that she and reverse-flash are trying to
make more to the Sabbat ARB at all I got
a lot of questions about why Nora didn't
create time remnants when she went back
in time whenever she uses her ability in
the only explanation that I could offer
is that her ability doesn't work exactly
like traditional time travel like the
way she rewinds time is just a little
bit different from the way that Barry
would go back in time using the Speed
Force you actually also have to kind of
create a time remnant on purpose like
you have to go find one from a previous
timeline grab them and pull them either
forward or backward or wherever it is
that you want to take them and get their
help so that's why you haven't suddenly
seen ass avatar version of Nora show up
on the TV show although I'm sure
there'll be some joke about that
eventually when crisis goes crazy and
blows up in everyone's faces like look
at what you've done to the timeline well
you are Barry Allen's daughter and he
definitely likes to screw the timeline
so no surprise that you would also do
the same thing in number one of course
reverse flash explaining his plan
literally Nora goes to him you're sure
we're not making things worse just
remembering the crisis on Infinite
Earths stuff is coming down the road of
course they're making things worse but
reverse flash gets pissed one because
remember there's a ticking clock on his
life he's probably gonna be executed by
the prison when that clock runs out into
also his hubris like I am the smartest
person of course I should be able to
figure out how to mess with the timeline
without all these consequences happening
but it's usually his hubris that gets
him into trouble like yes he is smarter
than everyone else but it's all about
his overconfidence so just a reminder
about what he says he says one they're
gonna defeat cicada then to destroy his
dagger notice that he specifically
mentions cicadas dagger which is why I
think they're gonna try and pay off some
big comic book Easter eggs for
reverse-flash with the dagger or later
this season and then say Barry Allen of
course they're trying to say Barry Allen
but that's not the last thing on reverse
flashes list the other really cool thing
too is that Sherlock scene at the end
where you see him used the notes that
Nora wrote down like she decoded some of
the symbols on that dry erase board
Sherlock to use those clues to
completely decode her entire time
Journal so what'll probably happen is is
maybe not in the next episode but the
episode after that the computer will
finish completely decoding everything
completely revealing reverse-flash and
Nora's planned to him then he'll
confront the rest of the team with it
the really important reminder though
that flash episode 15 the Grodd versus
King shark episode isn't going to happen
for three weeks there'll be a three week
break so I'll remind everyone when I
post my trailer video in the morning
also name a giveaway winner during that
click here for my brand-new Game of
Thrones Season eight deleted sea video
and click here for my brand-new Captain
Marvel and Avengers endgame trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]